المترجم: Alamir Mina
المدقّق: Riyad Almubarak
السلام عليكم
أنا مايا بخش
عمري عشر سنين
موهبتي الإنشاد والتمثيل
أود أن أخبركم كيف بدأت الإنشاد
ولكن أولا أريد أن أسألكم سؤالاً
من منكم يحب الإنشاد مثلي؟
(أصوات الجمهور)
ما شاء الله
هذا يعني أن هناك من يهتم
يهتم بكلامي
أعني
وحتي من لا يحب الإنشاد يود أن يسمع لي أيضا
ربما أدفعه إلى حب الإنشاد
حسنا
سأخبركم كيف بدأت
عندما كان عمري أربع سنوات
كنت...
أعني أنني لم يكن لدي مايكروفون ولا مسرح
ولا أي شيء ...
حسنا
كنت أتخيل أن المخدة هي المسرح
كنت أتخيل أن الوردة هي المايكروفون
وكنت أرتدي فستان وطوق
تلك الأشياء...
وأصعد المسرح
على المخدات
وبعد أن أشغل التلفاز وأشاهد أطفال ينشدون
بالطبع، أنا أعتبر أن هؤلاء الأطفال
هم جمهور حقيقي
وأظل أنشد...
(تصفيق)
ثم أصبح عمري خمس سنوات
تحققت أمنيتي
وأصحبت أصعد المسرح
لم يكن هناك إعلام ولا كاميرات ولا تليفزيون
عندما أصبح عمري سبع سنوات
أصبحت أصعد المسرح
وأصبح هناك إعلام وكاميرات وتليفزيون
كل شيء، لقد تحققت أمنيتي
وبالطبع أنا
لا أحب فقط أن أسعد الناس الذين
مثلكم أنتم
ليس أنتم فقط
من تتوقعون؟
من؟
من؟ حسنا، سأخبركم
من لا يستطيعون السمع أو النظر
ومن لا يستطيعون المشي
أعني، من لا يسمع يمكن أن ينظر
ومن لا ينظر يستطيع أن يسمع
من لا يمكنهم النظر يسمعون
وأيضا من لا يسمعون يمكن أن يشاهدوا
يشاهدوا حركاتي
ينظرون تعبيرات وجهي كيف تبدو
وهكذا
وطبعا أنا
أحيانا أحب الإنشاد
حسنا
(تصفيق)
في أوقات الفراغ
لا أتصفح موقع يوتيوب أو أي شيء
وأشاهد... أعني كلمات...
أعني أشياء غير هادفة
أحب الأناشيد الهادفة
يعني مثلا عن ال...
الخير..عن ال ..أعني أي شيء مفيد
حسن الخلق... عن أي شيء هادف
أعني.. كلماته هادفة أعني أنني أحبه...
وأنشدها
وبالطبع أحفظها وأنشدها وأصعد المسرح وهكذا
حسنا...
أيها الطفل.. عندما تكون لديك موهبة
لا تخفيها
قائلا أنا خجول.. لن أخبر أمي، انني خجول
لا ...لا..
أعني أنني...
يجب عليك كطفل أن تذهب إلى والدتك
أو... أي أحد من أسرتك
ويجب على الأم ألا تتجاهله
الأفضل أن تشجعيه على إظهار موهبته
أعني.. لكي يستفيد ويعلم أطفاله
عندما يكبر...
وهو أيضا يستفيد
حسنا
أنا موهبتي الغناء والتمثيل
وسرعة إتقان الحركات
(تصفيق)
سوف أغني لكم في آخر اللقاء
حسنا، لقد كنت
أعني، كنت أتمنى أن أصور مقطع فيديو
ولكن هذا المقطع...
يكلف الكتير من المال
أعني أنني...
أحب أبي ولا أريد أن أسبب له المتاعب وهكذا
ثم جاءتني فكرة...
ما هي الفكرة؟ لست أعرف
حسنا... فكرت... ثم تساءلت
مين يصور لي مقطع الفيديو؟ من؟
من يمكنه أن يفعل ذلك؟
وجدتها!
مين سيصور لي مقطع الفيديو؟
(همهمة الجمهور)
أخاك
أليس كذلك!
أخي عبد العزيز
أخي عبدالعزيز ممنتج ومصور ومخرج
أعني أنه أيضا يحب المنتاج والتصوير وهكذا
ففكرت لماذا لا يقوم هو بالتصوير
والمونتاج وكل شيء
وأخي الصغير إبراهيم
عمره تلات سنوات
طبعا هو
يمثل معي
لقد تحققت أمنيتي... تحققت
وقمت بعمل مقطع الفيديو
حسنا
مين يريدني أن أنشد له؟
(أنا... أنا... أنا)
حسناً
ماذا أغني؟
حسناً...
اااه الأول، يا فل يا كادي يا كمل
يا أهل الأدب والذوق وعشت وبقيت مجمل
يا أهل الطيبة والرقة
والهرج المتبت بالدقة
ورب البيت وحشتوني
من التاجر إلى السقا
أهل أول وحشني حتى فرقنا
بهندسته وبقشة قماش
وعم شاكر في دكانه
بالفوطه وقميصه الشاش
وحشتني حلاوة اللدو
والبركه الي في يده
وحشتني الكحله في عيونه
وحوا والصبي عبده
وحشني كل ما فيكم
ياناس حتى أساميكم
ياريت ترجع لنا الأيام
وأسلم على أياديكم
واشم ريحة الرضا فيها
وأشياء ما أقدر أسميها
حاجات كدا ترد الروح
صعب أوصف معانيها
(تصفيق)
اااه اهل الاول
شكرا
الآن، ليتفضل معي
ابراهيم وعبد العزيز
(تصفيق)
السلام عليكم
انا اسمي عبد العزيز محمد أسعد بخش
موهبتي المونتاج
ومهندس صوت
ومصور
ومخرج
وطبعا
مواهبي، لقد تعلمتها منذ الصغر
والحمد لله لقد تحققت الحمد لله
وأهلي اشتروا لي كاميرا والحمد لله
وأصبحت أصور مقاطع فيديو
وأقوم بعمل المونتاج لها والحمد لله
ونحن في المنزل لا نجلس ساكنين
دون أن نفعل أي شيء
لكننا نمسك أيادي بعضنا البعض
ونصور مقاطع، أعني، لا نبقى ساكنين دون نشاط
وهكذا نصور مقاطع فيديو ونستفيد
ومقاطع هادفة
صورت مقاطع فيديو بسيطة
لأختي مايا إبراهيم أيضا
تفضل
(تصفيق)
أنا اسمي إبراهيم
(ضحك) (تصفيق)
قمت بالتمثيل مع أختي مايا
(تصفيق)
شكرا
والآن سنعرض لكم مقطع الفيديو الذي صورناه
وإن شاء لله سيعجبكم
تفضلوا
(تصفيق)
شكرا
شوق يدفعني لأراها، أمي ذكري لا أنساها
طيف، أنقى،
من زبد الأيام أبقى
أمي... أمي... أمي
همساتها، أحلى من ناي
سكنت قلبي
كلماتها باتت نجواي
تضيء دربي
لا تنسى أخاك
ترعاه يداك
لو سرقت منا الأيام
قلبا معطاء بسام
لن نستسلم للآلام
لا تنسى أخاك
ترعاه يداك
ولا تنسوا أن تتعاونوا مع إخوانكم
وتتشاركوا
شكرا
(تصفيق)
ما شاء الله تبارك الله
أشكرهم على مجهودهم الرائع
ما شا لله عليهم إنهم عائلة فنية متكاملة
أما الآن ننتقل إلى موضوعنا التالي